sara artist que es una madre ucraniana
que huyó con su esposo e hijo de 10 años
tras la guerra con rusia atravesó más de
5 países hasta llegar a mexico para
conseguir asilo político en eeuu junto
con su familia sara es sobreviviente por
segunda vez de un conflicto bélico el
primero lo vivió hace ocho años en
tumbas
en europa ya no hay espacio las personas
ya no tienen donde dormir o donde vivir
está lleno más me duele cuando mi hijo
me pregunta mami si la guerra comenzó ya
entonces voy a morir es terrible eso mi
único sueño como madre es pedir que mi
hijo pueda vivir maría es una joven de
20 años viajó sola estaba a punto de
graduarse de la carrera de computación y
dejó a su madre en ucrania para reunirse
con su hermana
yo estaba en polonia por una semana
aproximadamente estuve también en
alemania luego viajé a méxico en cancún
y finalmente aquí estoy
quiero reunirme con mi hermana que está
en eeuu sólo quiero estar con él
fuera del albergue instalado en la
unidad deportiva benito juárez en el
centro de ti familiares de ucranianos
intentan reunirse con los suyos como
víctor desde hace 8 años vive en nueva
york' su hermano y su cuñada perdieron
todo tras la guerra
mi hermana trabaja en un consultorio
dental mi cuñado y mi hermano tenían un
taller de autos desafortunadamente el
negocio quebró yo solo espero que el
proceso sea rápido me gustaría que las
autoridades agilicen el trámite y ayuden
a que las familias ucranianas se reúnan
nuevamente
cada hora son transportados de este
albergue cerca de 100 ucranianos al paso
internacional de cruce entre tijuana y
san diego para ser entrevistados por las
autoridades norteamericanas adultos y
niños se esperan encontrar en un nuevo
país la esperanza de vivir en paz en
tiempos de guerra